[Applaudissements]
l'adjectif dadidou pas franchement ouais
franchement ouais franchement c'est un
exemple de réussite
c'est enfin non c'est dingue c'est
dingue ce qu'il a fait c'est qu'il a
créé et en plus moi je suis un grand
droit j'ai vraiment aimé la
collaboration avec l'école j'étais sur
thalys
mais c'est un trip de fait à dieu mais
l'appel à l'époque école parce que moi
j'ai aimé chez métro je suis un grand
fan des connes donc quand j'ai vu la
collaboration en plus j'ai vraiment sûr
qui fait donc voilà passez le bonjour je
suis là depuis lé là il va falloir
passer le bonjour à akon de la part de
dazhou du ricanto tir n ya aucun
problème et mémé c'est vrai qu'il y
aille à quand je voyais alors je connais
plus son frère mais mais il ya quelque
chose quand même un peu la même vibe
il est vu sur les photos c'est tu mets
tes photos que normalement mais pas
quand on n'est pas sûr de soi relacer
monsieur d'état n'avait ou pas je suis
crashé à soi ça va ça va en ce moment tu
es bien là elle a dit franchement je te
le dis parce que je t'aime
comment tu as fait pour avoir l'autre
coiffure comme ça pendant des années la
personne qui m'a rien dit moi c'est là
qu'elle essaierait insurge aurait de
très durement mais c'est ça non mais
vous n'osez pas quand on est amis
normalement se dit moi quand tu veux
quand tu veux mais la carrière télé et
oui à huawei fait ces chiffres moi je
dis mais pourquoi j'avais des faits à
l'époque je sais que tu sortais tu te
disais je suis frais ouais ouais ouais
c'est sûr j'étais content
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
là on est bien moi quand je revois des
franchement et vous vous êtes des chiens
à voir et bien non mais moi mais c'est
bien la personne ne m'a rien dit j'ai
dit la même chose avec moi je l'aimais
mais pas me dire un truc sans rigoler le
pass 4 ans a rencontré oui/non latella t
elle là d'où il va enfin pas facile de
vous dire un truc à vous et moi je
reprends bien aujourd'hui on lui dit
david franchement c'est énorme dire tu
remplis en boîte c'est discrètement fait
si ce n'est que sa coupe est dégueulasse
ce rang depuis en boîte
alors c'est vrai show rock quand je
jouais au palace j'étais dans une cave
et j'avais juste une petite grille comme
ça où je voyais les pieds des gens mais
personne ne voyait
et tu vas arrêter de te [ __ ] de ma
gueule fr3 marguerite mais c'est à vous
que j'avoue que c'est un truc ça tout
regarder je peux plus jure je la vrai
problème c'est que des fois on me
demande pour des touchés pour des trucs
de presse et des photos je peux plus
envoyez rien tu es à moka qui a moins il
ya plus d'un ange cintala ce poids dans
l'horrible franchement toi tu as fait
comme ça la douche froide
toi qui connais les side a tout foutu
mais les frères regard est obligé de
mettre une moumoute heures ouais c'est
des moments ça sauve à l'époque il
fallait se trouve à limoges a été fait à
l'époque où nous voyons des dégâts
[Rires]
pourrait dépasser ou des franchement le
dj très très très bon délire oui je me
souviens d'être jouée à raison en fait
moi je vouvoyais ou aux bains douches
moi j'allais tout le temps d'un douche
et le filet comme ça un peu filasse
aujourd'hui c'était magnifique
bref à tout reda et moi et moi et moi je
vous dire moi je rêvais d'avoir cette
coupe et le problème c'est que moi avec
cette coupe
j'ai des sauveurs de tunisiens donc en
fait frère je sortais de chez moi
j'avais cette peau coogan et le deuil si
les matches avaient dû penneteau le
couteau c'est le problème c'est que ta
coupe à lemon pendant un quart d'heure
maintenant tu prennes la voiture et là
tu parles à une meuf et tu vois tes
copains tu ne regardes tu vois l'oeil de
tes copains qui m'ont gras regarde
toutes les bouches
et tu sais que tu en parles à laval et à
une peu comme mon frère lionel
catastrophe je partais david guetta au
bout d'une heure je t'ai laissé on va
faire après une faute sur david guetta
vrai ou faux le vrai faux allait arrêter
sa carrière quand david guetta doit
enregistrer titanium pré khuff eh oui
c'est vrai c'est vrai ce service est
vraiment si elle voulait arrêter
on voulait arrêter d'être artiste ouais
c'est ça et donc toi tu t'es tu le dis
non et tu vas faire titanium et je les
distances je t'en supplie reste sur ce
disque parce qu'elle voulait que ce soit
quelqu'un d'autre que le champ 56 ans
upm a dit d'accord ce sera la dernière
fois
ah ouais fou sauf moi
[Musique]
à
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on rappelle bien sûr le titanum pays
théâtre de plus spécial mois vrai ou
faux david guetta a participé à
l'émission d'humour la classe sur france
3 valérie bénaïm clos fo je veux dire
vrai ouais c'est vrai sans rigoler à
l'époque tu étais le dj de sydney le
fameux rappeur de l'émission hip hop tu
connais pas ça doit d'être nord alors si
c'est le premier café le quart année le
hip hop voilà et vous remplaciez la
halle le célèbre à la queue leu leu de
bézu pour terminer démission on aperçoit
même michèle laroque
regardez adore et on va voir qu'en fait
tu sais mixer dodo aussi regardent
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bref des transactions
où
et perd ce n'est qu'il est frais et le
jeune couple fait ça laisse de l'espace
à l époque il ya toi mais rigolo c'est
un peu maigre dans le sens et le sens où
c'est quoi l'océan
jean vincent collet il est arrivé la
boutique qui voulait tellement le jean
ils ont dit non on n'a de taille avec
une ceinture ça passera non chérie ça
passera qu'une junte une grosse qu il
est il ne voulait absolument à 6 ouf
connaissez ou alors vrai ou faux david
guetta rencontra un homonyme qui se sert
de son os pour mixer en boîte de nuit
c'est totalement faux mais bravo c'est
faux il a récemment parlé chez cauet
avec un homonyme qui a rencontre qu'a
raconté l'avantagent de s'appeler aussi
david guetta regarder ces deux cocos moi
aussi j'ai en fait je m'appelle david
guetta base pilier alors voilà c'est ça
exactement alors pas mal de noms
pourquoi vous important c'est son nom
non mais pour en choper on va dire
gagner que vous faut le plus grand fan
de david guetta plus de 70 en vrai si
vous posez c'est vrai je me dis vrai
c'est vrai tu connais ou pas on regarde
il est exceptionnel
[Musique]
et on aura de l'europe de kelly nous
faut david guetta a vendu autant
d'albums qu'il ya d'habitants en suède
vrai ou faux et vrai c'est vrai et ouais
dix millions dix millions c'est fait on
fout pas vrai ou faux david guetta a
signé son premier contrat en maison
disgrâce à mylène farmer avec tout bon
ce soir
et non c'est pas grâce à mylène farmer
c'est grâce au daf thomas minder
exactement wac a apporté ton premier
side est dans la maison de disques dans
laquelle tu as signé et ben merci à eux
en tout cas parce que voilà aujourd'hui
bombe à ccc un qui est comme un pouvoir
d'achat d'or évidemment je dors et déjà
rencontrés ont certes laissé beaucoup je
vous connais pas on a fait une émission
ensemble
j'adore évidemment c'est une idole
absolue
très beau gosse est ce que le changement
de coiffure peut faire aussi du coût des
changements dans une vie mais je suis
toujours été reçus
alors on va vous laisser son numéro
voilà une question est-ce qu avec justin
bieber ça s'est bien passé parce qu'on
m'a dit que c'était un peu un petit con
que ça c'était moyennement passé là là
là bas un vrai de vrai alors en vrai de
vrai voilà c'est là la séance la plus
facile que j'ai eue de toute ma vie
l'ancien à un vrai de vrai mais il a
alors cessé
je ne dis pas que c'est toujours comme
ça parce que j'ai entendu que ça pouvait
très bien mais moi ça a été super facile
et moi j'ai rencontré il était très
sympa dating il a pris ma carte s'est
régalé en faire un clip d'ailleurs tout
à l'heure oui moi et moi c'est mon idole
mais pour une autre raison qui nous
avait raconté une faute c'est que quand
il mixe il a rien à faire c'est l'homme
qui peut le plus pêché au monde
il est dans sa valise cabine il reçoit
la fin de la fin du mix10 est il à sa de
tapis de boulettes numéro de téléphone
et je voudrais te faire une petite
surprise ce soir s'il ya quelqu'un qui a
voulu te faire une petite vidéo dans là
c'est vrai les surprises pour toi david
fred rister 1
c'est l'intérêt est plus proches
collaborateurs il te suit depuis très
très longtemps et il a fait une vidéo
pour toi regarde pas salut mon david
c'est fred
alors je sais qu actuellement tu es en
pleine promo pour la sortie de ton
nouvel album seven
un album que tu as réalisé avec tout le
talent qu'on connaît de toi et toute la
passion de la musique comme d'habitude
et tu sais moi qui suis fan de foot si
dans le foot il y a m ba bê dans la
musique il y à david guetta
parce que toi aussi tu es extraordinaire
je t'embrasse
est ce que tu peux expliquer aux
téléspectateurs ce que tu fais avec fred
parce que c'est sain c'est vraiment un
collaborateur
alors alors fred c'est un ami avant tout
et on a fait on a certains des morceaux
ensemble ouais dont aga le feeling et
one love takes over donc c'est pas des
moindres et c'est quelqu'un que j'aime
beaucoup et qui est malheureusement en
train de se battre très dur avec un
cancer
donc c'est vrai qu'il a eu dans sa vie
neuf types de cancer différents
fred il a décidé aujourd'hui de vivre
sans se soigner voilà parce qu'ils
voient là il est un homme très très
courageux et ce soir donc il t'a laissé
un message et il a un message
voilà aussi pour toi parce que fred il
avec nous ce soir
[Applaudissements]
bien sûr
il parlait
[Applaudissements]
pour être avec mon prêtre cela fait très
plaisir te voir aller et ouais ouais ça
fait plaisir de voir tous les jours en
plus parler vrai ben voilà bah c'est ça
d'un peu le but un voyageur venu pour
faire une surprise à david hauss im
aimons parler de son album kiffe le
disque question on n'a pas le droit
merci mon frère d'être là techt écouter
vos besoins de l'ovaire et je suis très
content je suis très content il ya une
émission qui a suivi l'un de ses plus
grands fans
ces 66 minutes de m6 regarde jean marc
mode est expert comptable à roquefort la
bédoule il est atteint de david gettis
tu sa vie est un véritable enfer depuis
qu'il est possédé par la musique du
célèbre dj
bonsoir ça j'ai rendez vous avec jean
bodart laaziz un instant si vous faites
ce qu'auront à gastes agathe
madame vous avez votre pièce ben quoi
battre
bleach
m
david cette équipe le roi des francs
vème siècle c'était charlemagne louis
xiv ou clovis c'est clovis
[Musique]